one of the things that's really
interesting is that you manage billions
of dollars you've been doing this for
quite a long time very successful at
doing so
you
don't normally strike people from the
crypto community as why would anthony
scaramucci and skybridge be
participating here and when i talk to
you i think that you see kind of the
writing on the wall right the world is
shifting to this new digital economy and
it feels like uh based on what i know
that you're taking sky bridge and kind
of slowly starting to say hey look we
want to include this in kind of the
aperture of what we look at is there a
world where skybridge ever goes all in
on bitcoin cryptocurrencies or do you
think that having a parallel strategy is
kind of the winning strategy
and i'm as in as you can be yeah you
know i'm going to be 58 years old in
january i'm pretty in right i mean i got
a billion dollars of this stuff uh and
i've laid in i've got a a a uh etf those
are for my fuddy-duddy friends you
remember there's fudd which is fear
uncertainty and doubt and then you've
got fuddy-duddies which are these old
people that won't own bitcoin i created
crypt for them crpt
trades on the new york stock exchange
it's a crypto proxy effectively it's you
know microstrategy and coinbase and
marathon and so it has unbelievable
correlation to bitcoin
um i've raised an ethereum fund i think
you know i have an investment in
algorand which i think is a fascinating
technical property uh but i'm all in
we've got almost a billion dollars in
bitcoin
i wrote a book
and again anthony this is an
international bestseller
and if you don't believe me you can come
into my warehouse back here at sky
bridge where i've bought every share or
every book to make sure it
was i mean come on no one's ever bought
one of my books so i'll tell your
listeners
uh my email okay okay it's acaramucci at
skybridge.com if you want a copy of the
book you're listening to the pops
podcast i'll mail you one a scaramucci
skybridge.com
it's a short little pamphlet but it'll
explain it to your parents
okay it'll explain to your parents what
it is
and the subtitle is how i stop worrying
about cryptocurrency
and you should too so i'm all in it
it took me longer than you because i'm
an institutionalist i said to you
in our first podcast 100 million wallets
a place where i can store it and not
worry about it because i'm gonna be in
deep you know with nine figures if not
ten figures
and then the third thing is what's the
regulatory landscape
is the united states going to accept
this and so last year
right around this time all three of
those things seemed like they were going
to happen
uh and so then we started buying those
coins
and we're in and i expect our business
to continue to morph into more digital
assets but you asked me a really
good question that i want to answer
how does an old fart like me
see it
and the answer to that is i have to
listen to young farts like the three of
you
and and i think we make a very big
mistake generationally
if we're not listening to each other
like you guys could avail yourself to my
experience dealing with volatile markets
dealing with the ups and downs of
entrepreneurship
the humbling nature of life like if
you're having a bad day think of my ass
getting fired from the white house in
july of 19
you know july of 2017 july 31st as an
example right and so you can learn from
me in terms of how to roll with the
punches and bounce when you need to
but i can learn from you where the
future is going because you and your
team the best business show anthony
pompliano you guys are creating the
future that my children and
grandchildren are going to live in and
if i close my mind to that if i act like
the 97 year old charlie munger and i say
oh it's the worst thing that's ever
happened in civilization
that means i've lost my neuroplasticity
and i've lost my ability to adapt and
learn
so my
message to everybody listening everybody
watching you
we can learn from each other let's not
close our minds and reconfirm our biases
let's open our minds and let's
test our theories on each other and you
know i i want to say thank you i was
with michael saylor yesterday i thanked
him i want to say thank you to you
um you were very influential in helping
me see what was going on in the
blockchain and and and in bitcoin i i
appreciate it you you taught me plenty
don't you worry i i should be thanking
you not me uh not you taking me